I've always loved this genre David and
Goliath movies and that sort of underdog
thing and I think I grew up with
somebody you know who was kind of an
underdog in school and and then somebody
with you know bullied to a certain
extent so the idea of this being a movie
about people who feel powerless and see
that there's something wrong in the
world and go out and try to change it
was a story that I've always loved
seeing those kinds of stories in film
well I hadn't known Daniel I had seen
his first film phoebe in wonderland
which i liked a lot and so I was anxious
to talk to him about this and and he was
very seductive about what he wanted to
do with the movie and I joined it
relatively late you were the script is
had gone through a couple of iterations
and there were things I liked about it
and there are things that I thought
could be improved it was a great
collaboration we were sort of working on
the script of the script was being
written and rewritten while we were
preparing the movie and I just it i love
the ideas and daniel calls it a David
Goliath story but I love the idea of two
women who don't realize their power and
what they can do and in the end the
interest of improving their kids
education realize that you know the
message we certainly want to give is
that you can do something you can
actually do something about a situation
and not everything is impossible to
overcome and that's so we use movies
like Erin Brokovich or Norma Rae as
models of characters who don't even
suspect that they have it in them to to
to to mount this kind of offensive and
so I I it was one of the best
experiences I've had in making a movie
viologic an actress that I had revered
forever I didn't know that you'd never
met her no no no II think that ever
since I saw Antwone Fisher and she had
about four words in that film and and
and and and was mesmerizing so I wrote
it for her I I brought it to her and I
was you know I remember our first
meeting fairly
because uh you know we were showing up
and I was dying for her to do the role I
had never met her before and I was stuck
in traffic in midtown Manhattan and I
was trying to get meeting and I can't
stand being late so at a certain point I
had get out of the cab and I just broke
into a jog so I could get to this
meeting it's very hot and humid day so I
show up with the sweat pouring off of my
face and I have never looked more like
Albert Brooks and broadcast news and
viola was very sweet she took one look
at means that I think I'm gonna have a
glass of champagne perhaps you'd like
one too she knew and so and and you know
and she's wickedly smart and the thing
that she observed immediately about the
role was that the way that the role had
been constructed in the sort of
beginning of the film when she's more
shutdown was sort of what's coming alive
nicely but when she gets to the point
where she really begins to discover her
voice that some of those scenes needed
to be built out a bit more and I think
they gave rise to some of what I think
ended up being some some of the most
captivating scenes in the movie
including when she was you know sitting
with all the teachers and she sort of
just breaks loose with them there and
Maggie I I mean it's also an astonishing
actress and I think she has that sort of
fiery passion you know as a person so
when you were thinking about the role of
a fighter you know she just immediately
came to mind and and and and and I we
saw it her quite actively she also has
this sort of great warmth and as this
sort of you know she's sort of kind of
eternal optimist and I think one of the
things so interesting about watching her
performance is that she's you know she's
had all these setbacks that she gets she
just sort of keeps forging ahead and I
think those kinds of heroes are really
wonderful to see on screen for the
states that were offering the largest
rebates Pennsylvania was certainly one
of them and we like the idea of setting
it in Pittsburgh for up for a for a lot
of reasons and it was truly a great
place to shoot and it lent itself some
real I think Austin tissa tea and a
certain amount of a just a almost a
nondescript industrial city in America
it's not it's not so much Pittsburgh
it is one of those cities clearly not in
New York or Boston but it's a and it
just worked for the for us and for the
story and it was truly a terrific place
to shoot and the son of teachers and so
I wanted to make a movie that was going
to honor what I think is one of the
greatest and most difficult professions
that we have in this country and I
wanted Biola's story in particular to
resonate with teachers and to affirm
that the work that they do and so some
of the the greatest response that we've
gotten have been from teachers you know
who come out of the movie saying you
know this this I've taught for 40 years
this movie makes me want to go back into
the classroom or other people come out
and you know this movie makes me want to
become a teacher so the the actual
teachers themselves who come to see the
movie I think understand that the movie
is intended to be a great celebration of
the work that they do